because i guess as you get older you
know you won't be moving nearly as often
you know i still don't know if i'm going
to move in two years four years you know
but once i'm like 40 i'm probably going
to be staying there for a good amount of
time yeah exactly
wow
that is a late time to settle down yeah
brian's setting anytime soon are you
kidding me
no i i i get you unless i become a
billionaire hedge fund man then i'll
just buy 15 properties and live in
whichever wherever how sweet i want to
maybe fly off the private jet once
one day these stocks are gonna turn
green and i tell you man i tell you
you can't settle down if you're settled
in five different countries at the same
time
the grain big brain
because i i'm still going through that
phase where i'm like i'm in my 30s now i
should probably think about where i want
to settle down but that just like that
just like terrifies me i feel like
settling down is when you're
you know you know when you're stopped
when you're working in a place that you
feel like it's going to be your end home
i don't think i'm gonna live in japan
forever no um i can't speak the goddamn
language
and even if i did i'm like would i want
to raise a kid here probably not yeah um
so i don't know
yeah there's like a lot of there's a lot
of different factors that go into like
my long-term settlement like where i
would want to settle down like i do like
asian culture and you know
i i do like live in japan but a big
thing about asia is that i don't want my
kids to go to school here because my god
they put so much pressure on exams and
schooling here that i'm just like this
is this is too much this is too much i
remember i saw a post that was on
facebook you know japan per capita has
like the least exams of any country and
it was like before high school yeah and
i was like i was like oh that's great
yeah so just let them be happy until age
12 and then just [ __ ] them together
they're really happy and it's like give
them heaven for about 12 years and then
give them hell for the next three that
make that makes so much sense because
japanese kids are like so [ __ ] cute
like whenever you see school kids
they're so nice say hello you know they
they just they're just so inquisitive
and everything and then like you they
start suddenly it's like it's before
they learn right it's just like a flip
but i swear like every japanese teenager
goes to the same moody teenager face oh
yeah like it's it's like there is no
exception
i'm telling you kids get cocky when they
learn racism
as it is right it's like
it's just like because i can tell like
because you know sometimes with japanese
kids right
just from looking at them you don't know
how old these some of these kids are
like there are some like 10 year olds
that look 30 and there are some 30 year
olds that look 10. yeah you know so and
but like you can always tell though when
it's like a middle school japanese kid
and a high school japanese kid not from
their looks but from their attitude how
happy they are yeah how happy they are
yeah
and just from their attitude towards how
i guess they like talk to foreigners i
guess in a sense like yeah high school
students are very scared of talking yeah
they are but middle school and like
elementary school japanese kids love
talking to people
in the street
yeah yeah i'm not going around going
like hello to every child but yeah in my
older shoes in my old apartment the only
people who would ever like converse with
me are like the little kids yeah
whenever i get stuck in a lift and i'm
like oh what do you want to go to where
did you come from
i'm just like
what is going on they love talking to
and then it's some i don't know what
happens something in high school happens
where they just suddenly become paranoid
of foreign
they ruin their life yeah yes yeah and
then with the the expectations but you
also know but you also know which high
school student dropped out because
they're very happy yeah yeah they're
like oh yeah hello how are you yes i'm
not in school anymore doing really good
for myself thank you very much don't
have to go through 17 exams a year i
just wouldn't want my kid going through
the system yeah yeah same yeah also if
japanese banks are like this god knows
god knows what the rules are like were
japanese schools
oh my lord i think it depends like being
a parent having to deal with it it's
like i think i think though it depends
heavily on the school that you go to
like obviously like i think public
schools definitely have it the worst i
think yeah that's the same with any
country out there uh but you know if you
go to like if you take your kids like a
private school or even an international
school like i think it gets a little bit
better yeah probably
oh
i don't plan on having kids anytime soon
no i mean either that's that's that's a
problem for like future me to figure out
yeah yeah that's a trash taste episode
5000 i think yeah yeah yeah
definitely
episode 5 000. joey's kid [ __ ] himself
in school
am i right
can you relate